fin de l'unanimité opposition majorité
sur la nouvelle calédonie jacques chirac
train que le référendum du mois de
novembre ne soit une combine politique
meeting aérien une semaine après la
catastrophe de rammstein des mesures de
sécurité renforcées mais le spectacle
continue en france et en grande bretagne
où s'ouvre le salon de cambo épidémie de
fièvre jaune sans inviter dans l'ariège
où avait lieu ce week-end le championnat
du monde des chercheurs d'or madame
monsieur bonjour bonsoir
dimanche dernier la catastrophe du
meeting aérien de ramstein en allemagne
fédérale faisait 51 morts et 300 blessés
le gouvernement de bonn décide aussitôt
de limiter aux avions civils
ce type de spectacle mais il n'a pas été
suivi par d'autres pays qui ont
toutefois demandé aux organisateurs de
meeting aérien de renforcer les mesures
de sécurité
en effet il faut savoir que ces
démonstrations acrobatiques connaissent
un réel succès populaire et que par
ailleurs elle sont considérées comme un
faire-valoir indispensable pour
l'industrie aéronautique ainsi qu'en
témoigne l'ouverture aujourd'hui en
angleterre afin de moreau du plus grand
salon aéronautique européen avec celui
du bourges
toute cette semaine en angleterre les
plus prestigieuses patrouille militaire
aérienne compte y est représenté thierry
km
les mig arrive
les mig 29 dernier cri des chasseurs
soviétiques les occidentaux peuvent les
voir évoluer pour la première fois au
salon de farnborough après leur
atterrissage des pilotes soviétiques ont
salué leurs homologues britanniques qui
leur avait fait un brin d'escort
confirmation aussi de la préoccupation
majeure du moment pour nous dit le chef
d'escadrille le plus important c'est la
sécurité des démonstrations en vol
à farnborough les acrobaties aériennes
doivent d'abord être présenté face à un
comité d'experts résultat un seul
accident grave en trente cinq ans les
organisateurs peaufinent les règles de
présentation des appareils chaque année
depuis la fin de la deuxième guerre
mondiale
ici à 60 km de londres 700 constructeur
aéronautique parmi lesquels dassault
safran meeting aérien et acrobaties mais
aussi un marché de plus de 10 milliards
de francs de commandes
plus modestement les meetings aériens
sont donc également des spectacles ce
dimanche en france il y en avait deux
importants le premier à dinard le second
à roanne près de lyon où nous sommes
rendus pour voir si la catastrophe de la
semaine dernière en allemagne fédérale
avait eu des conséquences sur les
mesures de sécurité prises par les
organisateurs claude rey jean georges
badia dans le ciel spitfire à veiller
sur une forteresse volant
au sol les mesures de sécurité très
strictes ont été respectées pour le
meeting aérien de cet après midi à
roanne les organisateurs ont simplement
appliquer la stricte réglementation
française les avions ont donc volé un
peu plus haut au sol les spectateurs ont
utilisé des artifices pour se rapprocher
des appareils d'une part les avions ne
doivent jamais passé au dessus de la
foule et doit peut-être à une certains
auteurs suivants qui sont en formation
ou en solo et par ailleurs le public
doit être à une certaine distance de la
kz2 la piste qui est théoriquement est
fixé à 200 m et que en ce qui nous
concerne nous avons mis à 270 mètres
avec double rang de barrières on pas que
le public soit anglais de pensée de
l'autre côté du côté piste
les spectateurs en majorité des mordus
de la direction ne semblait vraiment pas
inquiets c'est parce qu'il ya eu
quelques fautes
sans produire une deuxième j'étais
moniteur parages de famille car on
croise au pilote l'avion piloté quo donc
des risques que sont les riches pourquoi
nous sommes excités mois aux 24 heures
du mans et belles voitures 40 warrap où
l'on n'a pas arrêté en fait impressionné
si petit peu comment ça qui pour ne pas
venir
la patrouille anglaise des raids un rose
a finalement renoncé à la réunion de
roanne car les normes françaises de
sécurité en vol sont trop contraignantes
pour leur programme d'approbation
la politique française le scandale
autour du jeu de mots de jean marie le
pen s'apaisent quelque peu ce soir et il
est relayé par le discours de rentrée du
président du rpr jacques chirac à la
baule intervenant devant les jeunes de
son mouvement
il voit dans le référendum sur la
nouvelle calédonie une combine
politicienne mais ce n'est que dans
quinze jours le rpr arrêtera
définitivement sa décision laurent bout
si pour bien conclure une université
d'été il faut garder le meilleur pour la
fin
stratégie oblige alors à la baule à
jacques chirac a parlé en dernier
refusant le terme de rentrée politique
il a disputé pendant deux heures avec
les jeunes de son parti
questions/réponses presque tous les
thèmes ont été abordés du sida l'europe
des élections américaines à la nouvelle
calédonie si jacques chirac approuve le
dialogue direct rpcr fln cas s il est
beaucoup plus réservé sur le référendum
et si monsieur rocard dont la seule
responsabilité au gouvernement semble
être relative à aux affaires de nouvelle
calédonie réussi à convaincre le
gouvernement et le chef de l'état comme
ils semblent d'utiliser le référendum
comme une espèce de combines
politiciennes et bien il se plantera
mais c'est au rpr lui même qui l'a
consacré la majeure partie de son
intervention
un petit coup de patte pour les
rénovateurs dans lesquelles il voit des
masochistes qui se marginalise un coup
de griffe pour ceux qui prônent
l'ouverture
en fait pendant deux heures jacques
chirac a surtout voulu positionner son
parti sur l'échiquier politique en le
définissant comme le grand parti
d'opposition en france
parachevant le travail des autres
dirigeants qui se sont succédé pendant
trois jours à la baule il a appelé à
l'unité du rpr à l'union de l'opposition
pour la reconquête du pouvoir
oui et ce matin toujours à la baule
charles pasqua avait également évoqué la
nouvelle calédonie pour dire qu'à titre
personnel il est plutôt pour le non au
référendum ajoutant que de 1986 à 1988
pendant que la droite jacques chirac
gouvernait l'elysée n'avait cessé
d'encourager les
indépendantistes du fln ks à s'opposer à
l'action du gouvernement le ministre de
la santé socialiste claude evin estime
que cette réaction est complètement
d'irresponsable et qu'elle pourrait
attiser de nouveaux feux en nouvelle
calédonie aux universités d'été du parti
républicain à chamonix ce monsieur
léotard avait également évoqué le
problème du référendum en nouvelle
calédonie il souhaite obtenir une
réponse concertée de l'opposition toute
entière et ajoute nous répondrons sur
l'avenir du territoire et non pas sur
celui de monsieur mitterrand
soyons plus raisonnable bien entendu
monsieur mitterrand n'a jamais posé une
question qui soit neutre
elles ont toujours été ambiguë elles ont
toujours eu une arrière-pensée un
arrière-fond partisans et bien soyons un
peu meilleur que lui
soyons un peu plus si vite que lui on
nous pose une question sur la nouvelle
calédonie nous répondrons sont la
nouvelle calédonie et non pas son parti
socialiste ou sur l'avenir de monsieur
mitterrand ou sur monsieur rocard à
faire du jeu de mots de jean marie le
pen durafour crématoire de vendredi
dernier fait encore malgré tout parler
de lui ce soir laurent fabius le
président de l'assemblée nationale
s'interroge comment dit-il comment un
homme comme le président du front
national peut réunir 14 % des voix à une
élection présidentielle
monsieur fabius le fait que sur le pen
soit insisté un antisémite c'est pas
nouveau et tout le monde le sait il ya
vu la sphère du détail
et puis il ya beaucoup d'autres choses
qui émaillent sa vie et tout le monde
sachant cela ce monsieur a obtenu aux
élections présidentielles plus de 14%
déboires et selon les différentes
élections il obtient entre 10 et 15% et
pour moi la vraie question qui est posée
ce soir ce n'est pas tellement la
question
il concerne monsieur le pen lui-même on
sait ce qu'il faut en penser
la vraie question qui est posée c'est
quelle maladie au type qui y est dans la
société française pour que tout le monde
sachant cela il y ait plus de 10% des
français qui continuent à voter pour un
homme et pour un parti le ministre de
l'économie et des finances monsieur
pierre bérégovoy a évoqué lui aussi ce
soir les propos de
jean-marie le pen déclarant il ne faut
pas que les responsables politiques se
contente de condamner ici ou là les
propos scandaleux de monsieur le pen
mais il faut qu'ils en tirent des
conséquences dans leur comportement et
puis monsieur bérégovoy est revenu à son
domaine celui des finances et de
l'économie pour préciser les allégements
fiscaux qu'il prévoit dans le prochain
budget il faut que nos entreprises
continuent à se moderniser et je me
félicite d'ailleurs de voir que à côté
des investissements de modernisation il
ya maintenant ce qu'on appelle des
investissements de capacité autrement
dit on augmente nos capacités de
production hors jeu que ça dure alors je
suis pas assuré que ça durera devant les
statisticiens ne le disent pas en 1989
voilà pourquoi je crois utile de faire
un geste en faveur des entreprises
un geste qui vise non pas à baisser le
taux de l'impôt sur les sociétés de
façon égale pour les bénéfices
distribués les bénéfices non distribués
je fais pour les bénéfices non
distribués parce que cela permet
d'encourager l'investissement et pour
les entreprises de main d'oeuvre
nous envisageons vu tout à l'heure un
allègement des charges sociales en
déplafonnement les cotisations
familiales suivant des modalités qui
seront arrêtés prochainement par
monsieur et 20 et par monsieur rockeur
sauf que tout cela va dans la bonne
direction pour à la fois continuer à
investir et d'autre part favoriser l'
embauche
j'exclus de la manière la plus formelle
un quelconque réalignement des parités à
l'intérieur du système monétaire
européen les revenus ont atteint une
stabilité malgré les remous qui a eu à
la fin de la semaine écoulée et dureront
des remous qui font varier les parités
dans les fourchettes établi mais pour ce
qui concerne la france nous excusions
tout ré alignement
notre économie est saine même s'il ya
encore que j'ai tout à l'heure quelques
efforts à faire pour l'améliorer gens
pas de dévaluation donc selon monsieur
bérégovoy et la nouveauté par rapport à
ce que l'on entrevoyait déjà la semaine
dernière c'est la réduction des charges
sociales qui pèsent sur les entreprises
voici maintenant comment pourrait se
concrétiser ces allégements de
prélèvements fiscaux décidée par le
gouvernement
claire chazal sur la cagnotte de 10 à 12
milliards de francs réservé aux
allègements d'impôts de l'an prochain
pierre bérégovoy veut attribuer la
moitié aux particuliers essentiellement
sous forme d'une baisse de la tva
cette baisse interviendrait surtout sur
les produits d'accès actuellement à 7 %
qui ne le seraient plus qu'à cinq et
demi pour cent comme les livres ou
encore les transports les loisirs le
cinéma le théâtre
théoriquement les consommateurs
devraient bénéficier d'un petit coup de
frein sur les prix rien de majeur à
attendre en revanche sur l'impôt sur le
revenu hormis quelques mesures
marginales comme l'amélioration des
déductions pour frais de garde ou pour
don à des associations pour les
entreprises c'est la baisse de l'impôt
sur les bénéfices réinvestis qui est
privilégiée le taux en serait ramené de
42 à 30 9%
la mesure pourrait intervenir dès 1988
en matière de fiscalité pétrolière enfin
le gouvernement ne procèdera l'an
prochain qu'à une réduction de la taxe
sur l'essence sans plomb à l'étranger
l'italie commémore est aujourd'hui le
sixième anniversaire de la mort du
général dalla chiesa
après avoir vaincu le terrorisme les
brigades rouges il avait été envoyé en
sicile pour traquer la mafia celle ci
décida alors de l'exécuter depuis ses
successeurs ont essayé de reprendre le
flambeau du général mais en désespoir de
cause au début du mois d'août dernier le
juge falcone est décidé d'abandonner
faute de moyens dit il le gouvernement
italien au pied du mur décidé alors de
mettre au point un nouveau plan anti
mafia qui a été rendu public cette
semaine
rémy roche palerme 3 septembre 1982 le
général de la caisse ça préfet
anti-mafia redouté tombent sous les
balles d'une mitraillette aucun doute
quant au commanditaire de l'assassinât
d'els acquiesce à était devenue le
symbole de la lutte
contre la pieuvre hier des milliers de
palerme ita on célébrait l'anniversaire
de sa mort au cours de diverses
manifestations et cérémonies en se
rendant notamment sur les lieux de
l'attentât
la veille le gouvernement italien a
annoncé qu'un nouveau et solide plan
anti mafia était bouclé un mois après le
coup de colère du célèbre juge falcone
est lui aussi entièrement dévouée à la
lutte contre la mafia qui estimait ne
plus disposer de moyens suffisants à sa
croisade
c'est lui qui avait traîné des centaines
de mafiosi devant un tribunal
lors du fameux procès du siècle le
projet de loi du gouvernement donne le
haut commissaire chargé de coordonner la
lutte anti-mafia pratiquement les pleins
pouvoirs en tout cas plus qu'il n'avait
jamais été donnée à ceux qui eurent à
traiter du terrorisme
outre la possibilité d'avoir accès et de
contrôler toutes les transactions
financières et donc de déjouer les
mouvements de fonds de la mafia le
haut-commissaire verrait ses moyens en
homme et son budget sensiblement
renforcé le texte devrait être
rapidement présenté au parlement
il fait déjà pratiquement l'unanimité en
italie
en dehors de quelques réserves émises
par le parti socialiste au nom de la
défense des libertés individuelles
à genève les négociations entre l'iran
et l'irak piétine l'irak accuse d'iran
de bloquer la discussion sur des points
de détail pour autant le cessez le feu
tient toujours et le gouvernement
français vient de décider de rapatrier
le porte avions clemenceau et quatre
autres navires qui patrouillaient dans
le golfe et l'océan indien
l'italie a déjà quant à elle retirer
l'essentiel de ses bâtiments
le ministre de la défense français
monsieur chevènement a précisé qu'à tout
moment l'autre porte avions de notre
flotte le fauche pourrait appareiller et
rejoindre cette zone si la situation
l'exigé
polémique également autour de l'arrivée
de plusieurs milliers de réfugiés kurdes
en turquie chassés par l'armée irakienne
qui selon le témoignage de
l'organisation amnesty international
aurait utilisé contre ses populations
kurdes des armes chimiques ce qui est
démenti en turquie corinne pertuis ils
ont réussi à franchir la frontière
et pourtant ils ont peur les cent mille
kurdes réfugiés depuis le début de la
semaine en turquie redoute à tout moment
un raid de l'armée irakienne à quelques
kilomètres de là seulement les
bombardements systématiques des villages
kurdes se poursuivre ces familles
attendent leur transfert en l'armée
turque dans des constitue à une centaine
de kilomètres plus au nord en direction
de la frontière iranienne
là elles se sentiront en sécurité dans
un rapport publié à londres
amnistie internationale accusent l'iran
de vouloir éliminer systématiquement la
population kurde et d'utiliser pour cela
des armes chimiques
les médecins turcs dépêchés sur les
lieux affirme qu'aucun réfugie blessés
ne l'était par armes chimiques
il est vrai que pour le gouvernement
turc l'afflux de ces réfugiés pose un
problème délicat la question kurde
existe également en turquie les camps de
réfugiés sont provisoires insistent les
autorités turques
mais déjà il est plus difficile aux
kurdes aux irakiens de venir se réfugier
en turquie l'armée irakienne a pris
position le long de la frontière pour
les empêcher de passer en israël
l'attitude de l'armée dans les
territoires occupés de nouveau en
question une enquête a été ordonnée
après que des témoins eurent révélé que
des soldats israéliens avaient pendant
une semaine et plusieurs heures par jour
dit ont transporté attaché sur le capot
de leur véhicule un palestinien accusés
d'avoir peint des graffitis anti
israéliens sur les murs de la ville de
jéricho
parallèlement le gouvernement de
jérusalem essaie de mettre un terme à la
révolte palestinienne qui dure depuis
plus de 9 mois maintenant
en procédant en procédant à des saisies
chez des commerçants ou des industriels
palestiniens qui en raison des grèves à
répétition et de la récession économique
qui s'en suit ou bien volontairement ne
paye plus linteau charles enderlin
la rue principale de bethléem 11h
mercredi l'administration militaire
saisi les machines d'abdel aziz ramdane
le menuisier
les autorités affirment qu'il doit au
fisc
l'équivalent de 480 mille francs une
somme qu'ils estiment injustifiée je
n'ai plus rien je ne peux plus
travailler
je suis au chômage jeu dépend
entièrement de la miséricorde de dieu
ce cas date d'il y a cinq ans avant le
soulèvement avant les problèmes dans la
région
et si quelqu'un ne veut pas payer
le gouvernement doit faire quelque chose
autrement
personne ne payera depuis quelques mois
l'administration militaire ne fait pas
de cadeau aux contribuables palestiniens
elle a riposté par des saisies aux
appels au boycottage des impôts lancé
par le comité clandestins du soulèvement
en avril 87 le fisc a réclamé alias
matar un quincaillier cinq cent mille
shekels 2 millions de francs il s'est
précipité chez le percepteur et la somme
a été ramené à 48 mille francs l'afer a
traîné devant les tribunaux
jusqu'au mois dernier ils sont venus me
saisir la voiture parce que j'ai refusé
de leur payer une avance en raison du
soulèvement l'activité commerciale est
presque nul
nous gagnons très peu et puis nous
commençons à comprendre qu'il ne faut
pas payer les impôts de l'occupant pour
les autorités militaires l'enjeu est
fondamental
il s'agit d'assurer des rentrées
fiscales suffisantes pour administrer la
cisjordanie et notamment payer les
salaires des quatorze mille employés
palestiniens des services civils
effectivement parce que les impôts ont
baissé au niveau des rentrées nous avons
dû
disons baisser certaines choses comme
par exemple le budget de développement
mais on n'a pas du tout atteint le
budget courant c'est-à-dire les salaires
et les choses comme cela et pour obtenir
n'importe quel document de
l'administration a laissé passer un visa
et palestiniens doivent d'abord recevoir
une autorisation du percepteur régler
toute leur tête du travail pour les
écrivains publics qui remplissent les
formulaires et bénéficient donc de cette
situation ce sont les seuls gagnants de
la guerre des impôts inondations
particulièrement catastrophique cette
année au bangladesh ou sept actuellement
la période de la mousson marquait donc
par des pluies diluviennes 25 millions
de sans abri dit en 500 victimes
inondations également en chine
éric perrin les catastrophes naturelles
s'acharne sur l'asie plus de 25 millions
de sans abri subissent les caprices du
temps depuis le début de l'année en
chine dans les trois provinces
concernées on estime les dégâts à 12
milliards de francs
ce sont les inondations les plus
importantes depuis 40 ans il y a
plusieurs centaines de morts dans le
nord trente mille hectares de champs
sont totalement détruits les secours
s'organisent les volontaires travaillent
24 heures sur 24 pour construire des
digues de fortune et sauver ce qui peut
être sauvé le sol est comme une éponge
les glissements terreur emporte tout sur
leur passage
le gouvernement chinois espère dz de
l'étranger
au bangladesh la situation est tout
aussi préoccupante
les inondations ont fait au moins 500
morts il y à plus de 25 millions de sans
abri l'approvisionnement en eau et en
électricité est coupée 8 million de
maisons ont été submergées
dhaka la capitale est totalement sous
les eaux l'aéroport et les routes étant
inutilisable le pays est isolé du reste
du monde
le ministre des affaires étrangères du
bangladesh a déclaré que devant
l'ampleur de la catastrophe
son pays avait lui aussi besoin d'être
international plusieurs nations dont les
etats-unis la grande-bretagne ont déjà
proposé du matériel et de la nourriture
retour en france avec
un championnat du monde peu banal celui
des chercheurs d'or dans l'ariège une
région on a toujours beaucoup cherché et
peut trouver il faut bien l'avouer
delphine de la selle et philippe
montoise y sont allés voir ces
championnats le fatah younès est fermé
depuis 1954
on a parlé on a rêvé d'or il on a trouvé
que du plomb un gramme ou d'eau par
tonne de minerai extrait le métal
précieux n'a jamais été exploité trop
peu rentable et pourtant
légende ou réalité l'histoire de
l'ariège se confond souvent avec celle
des chercheurs d'or
alors ici moi je crois que c'est d'abord
la mite etc et puis ensuite c'est une
exploitation touristique quoi c'est
amusant de faire ben même de l'avion
pour des gens qui n'ont jamais fait de
vous trouver quelques paillettes
professionnels ou amateurs
la cueillette de payolle d'or remporté
un franc succès dans l'ariège depuis une
semaine la ville de foix senti aux
couleurs du championnat et le stade
municipal s'est transformé en village de
pionnier civilisation à part entière
laura son univers ses hommes son
commerce
mais je suis moi-même orpailleurs depuis
1982 je vis de la récupération de l'or
sur les rivières de l'ariège je retire à
environ 1 kg par an ce qui me fait un
salaire approximatif de 60 mille francs
par an mais je revalorise mais
particules d'or
les bandas sont les bijoux ce qui
augmente ce monde salaires ruée vers
l'or conquête du titre de champion du
monde
des centaines d'hommes et de femmes
venus des quatre coins de la terre ont
laissé tomber l'espace d'un rêve leurs
préoccupations quotidiennes
ce garagiste avions
je suis chercheur d'or amateurs un look
casual au purin solo ça mon dieu tu
devrais je prouve les loisirs
moi je suis restaurateur mais mon dada
c'est l'or l'or c'est une patience et
c'est l'ours est fabuleux c'est comme
c'est un rêve c'est pour certains
l'occasion de marcher sur les traces de
jack london ou dame très beau gars mais
pour les plus réalistes
le véritable filon c'est encore le
tourisme premier des deux concerts
parisiens de la tournée mondiale
d'amnesty international commémorant le
40e anniversaire de la déclaration
universelle des droits de l'homme
le président de la république monsieur
mitterrand avait adressé un message aux
spectateurs cet après midi à bercy
message ainsi rédigé quarante ans après
l'adoption par les nations unies de la
déclaration universelle des droits de
l'homme
comment ne pas être frappé dit le
président de république par le spectacle
d'un monde où la liberté les uns
s'accommode de trop souvent de
l'asservissement des autres jean marc
barr amie françoise avis
une voix noire qui chante pour les
droits de l'homme cette fois-ci chapman
une voix blanche qui lui répond celle de
michel jonasz avec bruce springsteen
youssou ndour sting et peter gabriel
ils forment la galaxie rock de la
tournée mondiale d'amnesty international
les raisons d'une telle initiative
chantal de casabianca représentante
d'amnesty international nous les donne à
l'initiative des chanteurs ting tings
tings et peter gabriel qui ont voulu
participer à cette tournée
internationale qui va durer six semaines
à travers le monde
l'objectif d' amnistie c'est de faire
connaître la déclaration universelle des
droits de l'homme
pour fêter le quarantième anniversaire
ou c'est un texte essentiel
tout avait commencé à 16 heures avec un
public chaleureux venus autant pour la
musique que pour les droits de l'homme à
l'instar de bernard giraudeau infidèle
d'amnesty pas seulement pour
reconditionner
les jeunes à ce que j'aime beaucoup il
aime passer ses lacets exceptionnel je
crois que les gens à travers ses
artistes ses chanteurs qui connaissent
très bien vont comprendre un certain
nombre de choses moi j'ai rien à
expliquer après famille et wembley
la tournée ira porter la bonne parole
sur chaque continent de l'argentine à la
hongrie en passant par le zimbabwe le
costa rica et le brésil
le sport avec les championnats d'europe
de ski nautique en grande bretagne un
titre mais pas pour l'habituelle
français patrice martin richard diot
passation de pouvoir en ski nautique
patrice martin battue c'est pierre
cardin qui a pris la vedette à son
camarade équipes aux championnats
d'europe à londres aujourd'hui ans au
karma a réalisé un bond de 56 mètres 60
nouveaux records de france
le français a plané sur les disciplines
la plus spectaculaire du ski nautique 56
m 67 encore à 7 m du record du monde
mais cette victoire est peut être un
nouveau tremplin pour carmin
médaille d'argent en slalom pour pierre
carmin encore lui battu sept fois par le
britannique maple champion d'europe l'an
dernier à marignane pierre cardin a
perdu son titre de slalom mais maple
possède un énorme avantage sur le
français il est professionnel et
s'entraîne en floride où on peut skier
12 mois sur 12
en quelque sorte il n'a que ça à faire
maple du ski martin blessé les français
ont quand même placé un skieur sur le
podium en plis durant la présence de luc
seigneur deuxième italien à l'itie est
le nouveau champion d'europe de la
discipline à l'itie a eu raison de
profiter de la blessure de patrice
martin car celui ci a horreur de faire
longtemps figure de figure en amphi du
lent
n'enlevez pas votre maillot de bain ça
sent encore bon les vacances de circuits
du championnat du monde de surf
s'arrêtait ce week end à biarritz c'est
l'australien glen wind tonnes qui a
remporté l'épreuve en réalisant une
figure unique vous la voyez le double
tube passé deux fois dans la vague
déferlante deux fois au cours de la même
présentation
le voici à vitesse normale pour la
beauté du geste que vous allez le revoir
au ralenti
le match
à
rien à ajouter coup de chapeau également
aux services des sports d'antenne 2 au
festival international de la vidéo
sportive d'arcachon deux distinctions
pour antenne 2 le grand prix du portrait
pour dominique le glou et son reportage
sur le champion du monde du 15 100
mètres en fauteuil roulant au
championnat du monde des handicapés et
le grand prix du direct pour samedi
passion spécial parachutisme proposé cet
été par gérard holtz et réalisé par
patrice ghost bravo messieurs
retour sur terre avec le tiercé qui se
courait cet après midi vous allez voir
s'inscrire sur votre écran les résultats
du tiercé et du kart et 12 14 5
voilà ce qu'il fallait jouer pour gagner
et pour ce qui concerne le quartier
vous ajoutez le 17 et vous gagnez un
petit peu plus de 18 mille francs voilà
ce journal est terminée le dernier vous
sera présenté en fin de programme par
philippe gassot tout de suite après
journal josé blanc la pierre les
prévisions météo demain matin un premier
rendez vous avec nous 6h45 télématin et
demain soir à 20h vous retrouverez ici
même henri sannier bonsoir excellente
soirée à samedi prochain